i prefer anything other than that sperm
sac it's not that it's a sperm sac is
that it tastes like [ __ ] if slump sucks
tasted good i'll chow down on one i
don't know i got no i got no resume he's
a joke he's a jojo fan yeah
he's practically my job
though is like it's the same thing with
me it's like i like it which fish is it
from by the way
i couldn't tell you what one of them but
like who did this this is some foods i'm
like who
who the japanese met like who opened
this fish up sure like the the
reproductive organ was like bruh you're
gonna eat this yeah but japan is the
country that's like oh this this fish is
poisonous
that and then they spend the next 100
years
training to eat the tiny little pot that
tastes like nothing do you like sea
urchin
yes i don't like sea chin right you
don't and then i i don't i it's really
strong flavor to be fair
is like one of the most like it's not
true it's very very strong one of the
most like polarizing sushi i think it's
like the wasabi of fish it's like it
like it feels like a a gas attack went
off in your mouth what are you talking
about for me yeah it's literally called
the butter of the sea it's smooth as
[ __ ] what are you doing it's so strong
what are you actually talking about
yeah i was like why is it a page that's
weird until i went to a place where they
like cracked that bad boy open in front
of me and scooped it out
and i was like oh
and i was watering right now connor i
could only get so erect come on i had
again i had reservations against it i
had sea urchin before i wasn't a fan you
know
you know it's it's a cool name yeah one
of the coolest fishes names out there in
english yeah sea urchin
urchin it sounds like some norse god
like you know what i mean it's like oh
like salmon i sleep sea urchin yeah it's
like something died to make this fish
right
so they crack it open and you know again
like with wasabi i don't typically like
wasabi at like the the the kind of
horseradish it's wasabi i'm not a big
fan of it but then you know i when i
went to a place and they gave real
wasabi i was like okay i'll give it a
chance yeah it was insanely different
amazing yeah actually amazing if you
don't like wasabi try the real stuff
it's insanely expensive but if you get a
chance i don't know how it just came up
you're not gonna get the chance no it's
it's i don't know how it came up it was
just in a course and they just brought
it out and they were like you grind it
i'm like i don't know it's very
expensive it's like asked me to grind a
diamond so
i i you know they crack it open they put
it on i'm like okay i try it it tastes
like [ __ ] still i couldn't i couldn't
enjoy it and i wanted to like it so
badly what what is it what is it that
you don't like about it because
because i've i've given sea urchin to a
bunch of friends who've come here
because i'm like whenever i whenever
friends come over and they want they say
i want to go eat some real sushi quite
quickly yeah i'm like all right but you
have to be open to trying some [ __ ] that
you're not going to get oh please yeah
thank you yeah you have your channel
yes yes
i'm like yeah i'm like okay i'll take
you to a certain place but you have to
be open to not just trying a [ __ ]
california role like you have to try
like some weird [ __ ] so are you prepared
for that and i always give them sea
urchin and it's like so far i think in
my with my group of friends it's been a
50 50. half of them love it and the
other half say that it's like too fishy
i think the problem with sea urchin is
that it's really easy to get bad quality
sea urchin yeah you need notoriously
like one of the fish that can make you
like sick yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
like i i've i've had bad sea urchin
before and it it tastes bad you know but
like if it's like really good quality
sea urchin like the freshest [ __ ] it's
like oyster like bad oyster is really
bad but good oyster is like
what i love about okay
okay
what i love about sea urchin is that it
literally i don't know how i can
describe it but it literally feels like
you are eating the sea that's just
that's kind of what it feels like to me
right no no
no no i agree all of it no because it's
like it's it's fishy but it also has
like a salty texture yeah yeah and it's
a little bit sweet it's a little bit
sweet
[Music]
it's kind of like
like downing some sea water but it
tastes actually nice it's really good
i've never heard somebody describe it
concentrate
it's like if you could take the essence
of the sea and put it into a food that
would be sea urchin
is a real one alien's a real one mainly
interesting
agree with me very international basis
you know when i go to like a sushi
restaurant where the the sushi chef what
is did you call a sushi chef do you is
it a sushi chef yeah yeah yeah it's just
a show filming did you master masturbate
she just goes to masters you know when
you go to restaurants where because you
know you can go to the
ones which are good too really cheap
really easy really nice or you can go to
ones where it's like a course yeah you
sit in front of it and at lunch menu
it's really pretty cheap in japan pretty
good and when i've gone there
always when searching comes up i do the
okay first of all i never ever waste the
sushi especially if the guy's right
there i wouldn't dare be like no i'm
okay yeah like i feel like that is like
a sin like you cannot look this i mean
i mean 20 years i think i'd rather like
slap his wife in the face
honestly yeah so like the sea urchin
comes out and and the thing is sometimes
if it's a really small restaurant they
watch you they watch you eat it because
they want to hear you say like oh it's
amazing that's good yeah i don't mind
because most of the time [ __ ] slaps and
i'm like oh there's another one this is
a good one oh keep it coming don't miss
it
oh that mackerel oh and he's like bring
out the next one i'm ready oh oh oh it's
snitching okay all right well
i'll get the water ready get the green
tea ready i just like put it all in one
and i'm like
mm-hmm
[Music]
wait but don't because most places like
that they tell you beforehand what fish
you like and what fish you don't like
right
shit's going so fast i don't even know
what they're saying half the time oh
okay so so so life hack for people
coming to japan i don't even know what's
the sea urchin name in japanese
so most places that aren't conveyed by
sushi and it's like a set course
the sheffield usually if it's a good
restaurant they'll come out and tell you
what fish do you not like yeah because
they're not gonna [ __ ] waste it on
someone who doesn't like that that's
actually i'm wasting this man's
ingredients so next time just say like
no uni
like apartments i paid for this course
i'm eating this i don't know i don't
even give a [ __ ] but i don't like it
i want to show full appreciation to this
guy in his craft
but you can by telling them that like
i'm not going to eat there is no bigger
compliment than me being like boss man
the rest of this food would bang in i'm
you know i don't have a faith if i was a
chef i'd rather you just straight up
tell me yeah what fish i don't know
i don't know man i'm too british sitting
there and watching you go
i don't no no no i wouldn't dare pull a
face bro it's it's a face it's it's mild
discomfort before the moment i put in my
mouth a stone cold face
[Music]